This is the correct way to write this condition.
In Python and most other programming languages, or has a little precedence than and.
And if you write this without parenthesis, the effect of this is that, this will be implicitly prioritize as this,
meaning that the condition that tag must be said applies only for single quotes
but not for double quotes which would always be stripped.
And this is the reason why double quotes are stripped whereas single quotes are not stripped.
Well, they are stripped but only when we are in tag mode
and when we are in tag mode, then the characters wont appear anyway.
We can apply this very same fix in our program simply by putting parenthesis
around this junction in here such as this junction takes precedence over the conjunction.
Let's see whether our example with the double quotes now works. Yes it does.
Now, we actually get the quotes properly in here. Let's try it a few more.
So let's see whether the single quotes still work too and while we read it
we can even add a few more to that--let's see what the output will be.
First example, with double quotes are still there, not stripped.
Second example, single quotes, not stripped.
Third example, just the HTML markup, HTML markup is stripped.
Next one, quotes around HTML markup, quotes remained, HTML markup stripped.
So HTML markup is removed in all cases.
How about our almost complex example, we have the reference with quotes within the tag.
Are they still properly stripped? We try this out. Yes, everything is properly stripped.
Quotes and greater than signs are handled just as they should be.